the fastest way to grow your company the
fastest way to grow your company is
through partnerships find people who are
already selling to your target audience
and have them recommend you to their
customers because now instead of selling
one two one two one two one two one
every time which can which can is so
slow and costs a lot of money and you
may burn out before you start making
anything instead of doing one to one
each time now you're talking to one
person who helped influence hundreds or
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
customers to come and find you this
comes as a result of a question for one
of my youtube viewers Saeed love you
guys on YouTube who wrote in to say have
been high please tell us how to
introduce ourselves and our profession
to the people who are in a group example
people who are praying in the cathedral
since there are good potentials we don't
want to talk one by one setting up a
booth in front of the complex is not
allowed in other words how to inform
them that we are doing what they want ok
so this is great first you figured out
who is that you're trying to target
you're targeting people who are going to
a cathedral the best way to do this is
not to be in the cathedral and talk to
people one by one or stalking them
outside the cathedral and trying to
bring them in one by one is getting the
people who are influencers at the
cathedral to support you so it's getting
the pastor's the priests it's getting
whoever's leading the the choir is
getting whoever's in charge of the
volunteers you want these people talking
about you and recommending whatever
product or service you have now how does
that happen you have to understand that
different people have different
motivations ok if you go up to the
pastor and say hey we've got this great
product and we're going to give you a
thirty percent cut of everything we sell
that may not be of too much interest
right the main abhi is motivated by
money if you're dealing with the church
I could be wrong but you have to find
out but you should be a known commodity
right they should know your name because
you're getting involved in all of the
fundraisers
you're there every Sunday at church you
are active in the community you're
volunteering they know who you are you
have to get on their radar and they have
to believe in what you're doing and then
you look for ways to work together right
you want them to talk about you if they
know that you're super passion about the
community and they know what your
company is all about then they're going
to talk about you naturally right
whenever somebody comes up to them with
a problem and they know you can help
solve them they're going to be passing
your name on so you want that
word-of-mouth marketing happening from
those key influencers but there may be
other things that you can do as well
could you put on a fundraiser for
example where you're promoting your
product and helping them raise money for
the church right what can you do what
can you do to work with these people to
get them to endorse and support your
product or service so step one is just
getting on their radar making
connections making introductions having
coffee with them seeing what's important
to them let them know what you're all
about and finding a way to work together
and then step two is having something a
little more formalized creating the
campaign together cream the fundraiser
together doing something more officially
together but that only happens when they
love what you're doing they believe in
what you're all about and they're happy
to recommend you so stop trying to sell
one by one by one the key thing here is
formed those partnerships to have those
guys help recommend you and again the
fastest way to grow your business is not
doing these individual sales but through
partnerships you're finding people who
already have your target audience
they're already talking to your target
customers and find a way to work with
them to help you grow your business
believe for those you're watching I love
to hear how you found partnerships to
help grow your business or any questions
you have around that leave in the
comments below I love Cena's come in you
guys like this video thumbs up below
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon
you